he stayed Roberts the Dodgers manager
and I got the Brewers game one coming up
on Friday night nationally championship
series congratulations so far how are
you skip Dan I'm doing well I'm doing
okay we were looking back on your career
and I didn't realize that you were a
pretty good quarterback coming out of
high school how good were you I was
actually you know before I had my ACL
reconstruction spring practice my soft
fear I was a better football player than
I was a baseball player I Jamel Holloway
Oklahoma mansoor option quarterback that
was my guy so that's who I kind of
emulated biggest offer came from whom
Air Force Academy and how close were you
in literature to Barry oh that was great
I yes I actually did my senior speech in
June I had my appointment and so I was
all set to go and then trim July I
pivoted and decided I didn't want to
play football or go over there first
Academy so then and my service to play
college baseball began in July but you
walked on at UCLA didn't you I did
because I got accepted to UC Berkeley so
in the UC system since I got accepted at
UC system it allowed me to get accepted
into UCLA and at that point in time when
you're looking at July and August full
starts in September obviously the
scholarships were already kind of
already set in stone and so Gary Adam
allowed me to be a recruited walk-on got
me into school and I made the club was
me was D Dallas and Air Force Academy
when you were going there he was number
six you were not going to beat out d
Dallas I liked it I liked it
right we were just talking about
starting pitching we were watching the
ALCS last night the Yankees couldn't get
their starters past three innings I'm
curious what your philosophy is a
what you hope to get out of your
starters no matter if it's you know
Kershaw or Hill whoever it might be what
do you what do you expect to get hope to
get so you know here's the thing is that
I think it's hard to put one specific
number but obviously I think that
because every pen is different and where
you're talking about how they been used
most up but I think obviously six is six
is probably the number that people talk
about these days and especially for my
postseason baseball but I will say this
one is that the thing that's challenging
for a manager now and you hear so much
there's so much pressure on a guy to go
to the pen early and a lot of it depends
on for me is how he's throwing and who
you got coming in so every manner he's
got to make that decision so but I do it
to your question it's six innings seems
seems reasonable but obviously I think
that our guys are so on the ball pretty
well and if you look at Houston the way
their guys are on the ball well you want
to get as many as you can attics trouble
you be talked out of taking somebody out
of the game a pitcher can very often
it's got to be the right guy and there
are certain parts of trying to build the
equity with the player in a certain spot
where something in your gut when you go
out to the mound and says there's
something in the boys the look in the
eye that says I believe this guy to get
to get through this inning or I'm just
not convinced but yes I can what do you
make of a Christian Yelich who's he
remind you of Shawn green Shawn green in
the sense that they kind of had that
same physique same look the left that
the left hand is bi builder Shawn Dean
hit the power early and the power came
later very athletic guys kind of similar
for me
yeah he's and he did it when you need
somebody to be an MVP that's why I mean
there were there were guys who were good
the
fire season I just thought Yelich when
the Brewers needed him came up and I
would be surprised if he's not the MVP
who do you think is the NBA I agree I
think you know there's so many good
players I was here talking about that
conversation but I think that with what
he did for that club and you look where
they were at at the all-star break where
he was really struggling the after the
all-star break he really took off and
really counted pulled to that ballclub
the cat's the Cubs and for me if I had a
vote that's what I'd give it to Dodger
manager Dave Roberts joining us
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
Clayton Kershaw said that he had nothing
to prove and he he went out and proved
whether he had nothing to prove or not
he was brilliant in Game two but did you
think like deep down he still had to
prove a little bit on this big stage I
don't think that you know in that one
particular game that's a moment where we
decided to start hunting were you
because of the rest factor where there
was a lot made of that I think the
question of the postseason is a bigger
question and that's a question Clayton
can answer but I think in that
particular situation I don't think that
I do believe that he does he has nothing
to prove but I do think that there's a
pride there's an ego component that
comes into it that wants to you know
pitch well and that's what he did but
also and I know that the media makes a
big deal out of this and I don't know
how much is coincidence I don't know
much how much is like that's just some
pitchers are wired differently when it
comes to the postseason and you were
there with Curt Schilling like there's
no better big-game pitcher that we've
seen in the last 20 years than Schilling
there was just something about that
moment but as a manager how do you
detect that if somebody has that or
they're missing that well I you know
what did I claimed 20 starts in the
postseason or 21 starts or whatever it
might be so I can't really go back and
look at every start but I will say I
will echo what you said about Curt
Schilling for me there's that no bigger
big games that I've seen the ability to
prepare and execute the way that she'll
did and and claim I think a part of it
is the execution and I also think that
just being able to use his entire pitch
mix and flip the script just a little
bit and I think that when teams
preparing a postseason that time that it
calls for that no because the
preparation is so kind of fine-tune how
many ticket requests have you received
you know what
so in this NLCS I'm going to Milwaukee
we're flying out tomorrow afternoon I've
got one ticket request and that's from
my side of travel beautiful well wait
you only had one ticket now that you've
mentioned this now you have you're gonna
have some new friends they're gonna say
hey I hear you got some tickets did you
watch the insolent Yankees I did I did
that's a good club over there you know
both those guys are good friends - far
as the managers that I got some coaches
obviously that I'm close to focusing on
both sides and the Red Sox that's a
that's a very offensive team and
Porcello threw the ball well and it
ended it being a lot closer than
everyone expected but yeah I think for
me the best team won we were talking
about pitching strategy or managerial
strategy with your pitchers I also look
at the certain teams are built for the
regular season I thought the Yankees
were built for the regular season they
were fun to watch but when you need to
manufacture that run when you need to
get a guy on get a guy over do small
things I just I didn't think the Yankees
were wired that way and I know that you
guys rely on the long ball as well eight
home runs in the series against the
Braves 13 of the 19 runs were driven in
via the home run are are you worried
that you're too self reliant on the home
run well I think and that's the thing
that you look at the Red Sox and you
look at the Astros are they kind of beat
you
a lot of differently but they can also
pitch but I think for us we can pitch
and that's your point about the question
about the offense we do walk a lot we
homer we do walk a lot and I think that
you know a lot of it so again is that
what you can get guys on base and create
stress of traffic you know the one hit
that you're looking for can put up a
crooked number but I think that yeah we
might not hit run as well as other clubs
or single but we do get guys on base our
today's baseball players better than
guys from 20 years ago I know better
condition better athletes are they
better baseball players than 20 years
ago we show you're talking about let's
look at it in two ways the position
player side now I think they're I think
they're stronger bigger stronger faster
but I think in a vacuum are they better
baseball players now and I think that
the players 20 years ago had more clubs
in their bag they could do a lot more
things on a baseball field they were
more in tune with you know they did a
lot of their own scouting oh by reading
swings and studying pitchers and keeping
their own books on pitchers where now
there's so much information and guys are
just relying on that and looking at a
car that's staying in a spot and even
not adjusted during an at-bat or making
nothing any at-bat as far as in the ball
so but the pitching side you're talking
about there's a lot of talent on you're
talking seven six five six guys so 95
plus that was never the case 20 years
ago so but as far as a position player
certainly for me but also I look back
and Randy Johnson could throw it as hard
as anybody he had to learn to become a
pitcher today's today's kids I don't
think are becoming pitchers I think
they're throwers now you do have the
exceptions and they do stand out because
they're true pitchers I I think that's
what's lost on this new generation of
pitchers is to understand how to be a
pitcher how to have the batter get
himself out Maddux used to throw hard
Nolan Ryan had to become you know from a
thrower to a pitcher
all of these guys it feels like and I
think that's what's missing today these
guys just go give me the ball on the
throw it as hard as I can until I need
Tommy John surgery well III think that
that's a little unfair man because I
think that though just because a lot of
times where guys that have velocity
they're just kind of put in the [ __ ] it
up Rover's and there's a lot of guys
that we could talk about that have
velocity that are pitchers and we saw
one the other night come in the eighth
inning in Chris Sale so and fer Landers
there's a lot of guys that Scherzer you
know he goes on and on the guys with
velocity so I think a little bit day and
I don't think that that's completely
fair all right well I've been known ever
known to be fair but you know I'm the
grumman oh I think I do but a lot of
times people make that decision when a
guy throws 90 that he's crafty he's
pitch ability and he can pitch and it
kind of takes away for the guys that do
throw hard but no you're definitely not
salty I love you could you steal the
base right now okay I just in case that
you know that they I'd still awkward
when I bring this up but playoff share I
don't know if it was voted on I think
you were checking with Kershaw and
Turner the last time is it just assumed
that I get a playoff share and hey if
they don't don't you want to take you
doesn't vote you well you're gonna chop
it up I share all right okay how much is
that where do we stand right okay here's
the deal
I'm coming out to Los Angeles and next
month mid-november
all right you can you can hold the
parade till then or we can get together
and and have dinner or both we can I'm
gonna do everything I can to hold the
parade off okay dinner is a deal okay
absolutely all right have fun in
Milwaukee and always great to catch up
with you Dave thanks for joining us
that's Dave Roberts for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]